you
we check our smartphones every 15
minutes or less and less on average that
is good for advertisers who's been an
estimated thirty 1 billion dollars on
social media in 2016 4 last night 60
minutes Anderson Cooper got a rare
insider's look at how Silicon Valley
gets users glued to their phones
he spoke with former Google product
manager Tristan Harris who owned a
software company before spending four
years at the tech giant Harris quit and
now advocates for better use of smart
devices
it absolutely wants one thing which is
your attention now he travels the
country trying to convince programmers
and anyone else will listen that the
business model of tech companies needs
to change he wants products designed to
make the best use of our time which not
just grab our attention do you think
parents understand the complexities of
what their kids are dealing with when
they're dealing with their their phone
dealing with apps and social media no
and I think this is really important
because there's a narrative that oh I
guess they're just doing this like we
used to gossip on the phone but what
this misses is that your telephone in
the 1970s didn't have a thousand
engineers on the other side of the
telephone who are redesigning it to work
with other telephones and then updating
the way your telephone worked every day
to be more and more persuasive that was
not true in the 1970s how many Silicon
Valley insiders are there speaking out
like you are not that many
Tristan Harris is with us now good
morning Tristan grabbing me okay so you
call this thing a slot machine slot
machine in our what does that mean
well it operates on a variable schedule
reward so sometimes you check your phone
and you're playing a slot machine and if
you get you know message from the person
you love or an email to show up on the
CBS Morning Show it feels really good
and then sometimes you check your phone
and there's nothing there and the fact
that sometimes you get something and
sometimes you don't is what makes it
just like a slot machine and and why is
that necessarily bad and what are
companies doing wrong here well it's not
that that's necessarily bad I mean we
just have to feel is that what you want
your phone to feel like do you want your
phone to feel like a slot machine the
the main narrative to correct
is that we have this belief that
technology is neutral and it's always
just up to us to choose what we post on
Facebook or how we use snapchat or what
we use our phone for what this misses is
that there's this attention economy
where every company needs to maximize
how much attention it gets from you and
there's a whole playbook of techniques
to do that and a slot machine is one
thing you can sprinkle on a product as a
way of getting people to use it more you
provided some specific examples last
night about how a company might do this
attention economy what's a good example
I think one that's more alarming is snap
streaks that snapchat which recently
went public because it's affecting kids
feelings of obligation to each other
what they do is they if you send a
message to someone and they send a
message back that's you do that several
days in a row they create a streak they
show a fireball and a number of the
number of days you've blown in a row and
a lot of kids have 150 200 300 streaks
and it stresses kids out because they
feel like if I don't get back to my
friend they're gonna be upset at me and
I have to do it and so you have kids
waking up and they've got to go through
and send photos of walls and ceilings
and drawers just to get through their
day and you have to ask is this being
done to help kids live their lives so
what would you do about it well we have
to change the incentives because right
now the incentives are to maximize time
spent if you tried to tell Facebook or
snapchat don't do that or this is you
know this is not we want they can't
because someone else will just swoop in
and get the attention so we have to have
a conversation about this attention
economy which is like the city that's
that's and we say how do we reorganize
the city let's not move out of the city
let's not just unplug I mean that's one
solution yeah but really we're gonna
have something in our pocket let's make
it work for us the reason I asked that
six minutes contact me several of the
biggest tech firms and no one no one
would speak on the record hmm yeah but
people like you the bet experienced
there know what's going on yeah I think
it's kind of the elephant in the room is
not so much that this is a
whistle-blower type thing I just think
that this conversation needs to happen
especially because in news it's
affecting our democracy because it's
happened at the same time as a rise of
fake news yeah well I mean if you have
two news feeds and one news feed is is
showing you stuff that's outrageous that
that just has unbelievable stuff and you
have to share it and you have to
can you believe that they said if
Facebook shows you that newsfeed it's
going to be better at getting your
attention than one in which they show
you some calm news about the same
important topics but the calm way so
they have to show you the one that is
more outrageous nationalism is really so
I think since fake sensationalism is
more important than fake news Wow just
done so great to have you here and for
starting this conversation was a great
piece last night and today as well thank
you it's written